Instead of just displaying values of individual
pixels I can display the values of the pixels
along a line in the scene. Let’s have a
look at this.
To do that I use the line button here and
I click the first point here and I am going
to click a second point over here. Draws a
line on the original image and in the other
window we see what we call an intensity profile.
So we can see that the intensity is initially
quite bright—we’re on the wall—then
as we move further towards the right along
that line the intensity drops, gets quite
dark in the doorway. If you come out of the
doorway and cross a section of wall again
the pixel values have got a large value, it
is a bright wall, and then they fall down
to a lower value as we go through the next
window.
So, this is the pattern of pixel values as
we move along a line within the original scene.
Another thing we can do is to create what
is called a region of interest, effectively
to zoom in onto a rectangular region within
the image. So let’s have a look at that.
What I will do is I will remove this profile
image and I will click the zoom button, and
I will lasso an area of the image interactively
and the result is a smaller image which contains
a sub region of the original image.